Sam before I start with you because
there's a lot of trade news that we got
to talk about well what's better right
now with the MBA is it the MBA drama or
is the MBA product the games that we're
seeing right now encourage thanks for
having me I appreciate it you know it's
it's question it's a good debate
I mean I'd probably say the drama you
know what I mean like it's that what
what blows me away about covering this
league is that you know the Intel that
is being gathered all around the league
right now about all the superstars who
are gonna work guys like Anthony Davis
who not up until the following summer
but certainly you know in the news right
now like that drives the decisions of
all these teams at the trade deadline
and so we have this clash between the
games themselves and all the action on
the court that is relevant you know
warriors playing better with Marcus
Cousins fitting in really well all these
different storylines but I mean the
stuff that relates to this offseason and
the kind of the bigger backdrop of all
the power plays and you know which teams
are gonna have the super teams and which
ones are gonna miss out
that's all very real and changing in
real time to it so we got two tracks
here and they're both pretty
entertaining so is that the big domino
that needs to fall right now is the
pelicans trade of Anthony Davis or are
we just gonna look around the NBA for
some other trace I feel like the Anthony
Davis situation is overshadowing kind of
what's going on around the NBA are we
just waiting for that Domino to drop I
think you can have other dominoes drop
first if I had you know it's a
handicapping right now in this moment it
could obviously change quickly I'd
probably say that ad stays put in New
Orleans past the deadline you know I
think that Boston package that is
available to New Orleans this summer you
know as everybody knows they can't get
involved right now but I think that's
probably enough to compel the pelicans
to wait and so you're gonna see other
stuff though I mean right now I'd say
it's all eyes on Memphis you got the
Mike Conley Marc Gasol situation you
know the Marc situation is interesting
because it looked like they were close
to a deal with Charlotte to send the big
fella love that direction I think that
certainly could still happen
but then the Grizzlies are in an
interesting spot where based on the the
type of drastic they have the first
rounder is going forward they have some
incentive not to totally bottom out from
a tanking standpoint so there's some
people are on the league who think that
they only want to give one of those guys
away
you know Mike Conley is a guy who's 32
you know is some health history of them
getting hurt but a heck of a ball player
all-star caliber you know who maybe Utah
San Antonio it seems like that
Indiana Toronto I know I've tried to get
after Mike and make that move
so I mean Memphis is now I think the new
epicenter next to the ad thing but you
know we got some moving parts here so
Sam you spend a lot of time on the west
coast and you know for us West Coasters
that mean that when you get late-night
news it's like it kind of wakes you up
and now you can't go to bed because 2:30
a.m. Eastern Time about 11:30 before
midnight here on the west coast there
was a trade by an LA team not the Lakers
but the Clippers at the 76ers for Tobias
Harris the Clippers acquire obviously
draft picks they'll get Wilson Chandler
a lot of expiring contracts well what
have the Clippers done in your eyes to
kind of set themselves a weather for the
rest of this season for next year in
this summer they're in a great spot it's
funny and apologies for being like a
minute late on our spot here I was on
the phone getting some clippers inside
there you go good read on it I mean
listen they I joked with somebody that
the headline on the Clippers story today
should have been you know Clippers
one-up the Knicks which is to say that
the other day the Knicks trade porzingis
they set the stage for the summer with
two max salary slots and basically all
eyes on Kevin Durant Kyrie Irving and
the idea that those two guys could go to
New York
the Clippers by making this move have
put themselves right in that game you
know they are definitely confident and
highly optimistic that Kawhi Leonard
would want to come their way this summer
leave Toronto put that Clippers Jersey
on and then from there they would love
to convince KD like you know all the
Intel right now is pointing towards
Kevin going to New York so we've got
time and things do change when it comes
to free agency and so that is still
their plan is Kawhi and KD from there
gets a little murky but bottom line you
know they have sent the message to I
think all the star players in this
league that they have an extremely
competent front office you know with
Lawrence Frank and michael winger and
those guys doing great work and Jerry
West as an advisor as well Steve Ballmer
cutting those checks they're putting a
really good package forward and you know
letting these players decide like do you
want to come kind of run clipper land
and have it alternative to the Laker
chaos that we're seeing unfold right now
senior writer senior mba writer for the
Athletics am aiming joining the Rich
Eisen show you can also follow him on
twitter at sam underscore Amick am i ck
is there a sort of I call it it always a
team that's lying in the weeds a little
bit Sam that we're not talking about now
but could make a maybe no say a big
splurge but a a trade that kind of
changes how we look at them for the rest
of this season is there kind of a dark
horse team that we're not talking about
that can make a trade and enlist in the
next twenty six hours yeah I mean I'm
not hearing anything specific the only
other bigger name that you know I think
is worth keeping an eye on is Nikhil
elusive it chef all-star really good
player the kind of guy that you know
he'd been tied to the Lakers at
different points in terms of different
possibilities and Orlando has a tough
decision to make this summer because
he's going to be a free agent and they
love them to death but it's just in the
way today's economics breakdown
you just have tough choices to make
because you can love a guy to death but
still just really not want to tie up
thirty million dollars in Katherine's to
that player it's just a lot of money and
the type of production he's been giving
them gets him into that conversation
about a max deal so booth ovitch you
know I don't know who is coming after
him right now and calling that magic for
an office but you know he comes to mind
and I think in terms of just aggressive
front office's I you know I mean Toronto
is definitely an interesting situation
because they've talked to Memphis about
my economy we hit on that and Masai
Ujiri heads up their front office is
very aggressive and he's already made
the move with Mars DeRozan going to San
Antonio and then you have the
complicated dynamic with Kyle Lowry who
was so tight with Tamar and you know it
seems like Messiah is trying
you know turn a new page and get a new
core out in Toronto we'll see if you can
get something done you know so I'm glad
you mentioned Toronto because that was
our poll question is that when you look
at the deal that the 76ers made with the
Clippers yesterday in acquiring Tobias
Harris
you mentioned Toronto with Kawhi Leonard
and and what they can do up there
obviously januzaj is a kupo in in
Milwaukee when you look at the Eastern
Conference right now with the trades
that have already taken place who do you
think is the favorite now in the Eastern
Conference um it's hard to say I've
always had like a personal policy of not
betting on the groups that I haven't
been able to see so Philly on paper like
you know they got to be in that
conversation I mean less talent wise
this idea of Ben Simmons do well and be
you know and and Jimmy out there and
until bias and then JJ reddick Lee's an
all-star caliber wing commits a heck of
a lineup that you're rolling out so
Phillies in the conversation I want to
see how those pieces fit I would still
probably point to Boston I feel like
Kyrie for all the headlines and all that
the recent kind of back and forth that
comes with him in his future
they've been playing pretty well and in
fact we had a good piece on our site
from my colleague Govardhan about Kyrie
and kind of his leadership style that
partly inspired by one of his favorite
players of all time the one and only
Kobe Bryant and that idea that conflict
can breed you know and then even chaos
can kind of take you to a new level as a
team and the Celtics you know I think
they could still find their way I think
they could still find kind of that
special formula to be the team that is
right there with the Warriors at the end
of the season because you know if you go
back to October in November before all
these different twists and turns you
know I remember talking to a lot of the
Warriors players and asking them to be
really candid like who do you think not
not who scares you the most because
they're not really afraid of anybody but
who matches up with you the toughest in
Boston would their take then and I think
probably still would be now senior NBA
writer for the Athletics ma McGuinness
and and Sam helped me out with this one
because tonight the New Orleans pelicans
take on the Chicago Bulls in Chicago
tonight 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time but Alvin
tree has said that even though he's
cleared to play with that finger
fracture Anthony Davis would not be
playing for the pelicans until after the
trade down to the trade deadline how do
they handle Anthony Davis after the
trade deadline if they don't trade him
how does that relationship kind of work
out for the rest of this season I don't
you know have total clarity on what the
move would be right if I had to lean one
way or another I think they probably got
to sit him I mean he is just a
tremendously valuable asset and I hate
to talk about human beings and that term
but I mean he's you know integral to the
future of both the pelicans and
whichever team ends up landing him and
nobody involved can afford fur I mean
look at this John Wallace situation just
the other day you know he was already
hurt then we got a torn Achilles you
know a B yeah right now if he gets on
the floor with the pelicans he's really
only doing it for I don't know what else
to say it but like self indulgent
purposes I get it you're a ball player
you want to compete but you made the
choice to go out and demand a trade and
this is the way business works so I'd be
surprised if we see him on the floor
again who knows maybe that will happen
but I think there's a lot of incentive
kind of from all sides to put him on the
shelf
you know Sam you've been covering the
NBA for well over two decades so when
you think to what we saw last night with
LeBron James and the Lakers going
against the Indiana Pacers last night
and just a picture of LeBron James at
the end of the bench with three seats
open or right next to him the fans
chanting to the players that LeBron is
gonna trade you and then you think of
LeBron getting hit while having his
worst loss of his career 42 points
there's a lot of young players on that
Lakers team that have not been through a
situation like this where they can be
traded what do the Lakers do going
forward if they don't have the tray for
ethany Davis what do they do going
forward to try to mend these fences of
players who are on the train deadlock I
mean listen I don't know how to say it
Kirk I think it's a complete disaster
when it comes to the black
ability to try to you know control the
chemistry I guess in that locker room I
think not that LeBron would ever admit
it but you know my two cents would be in
hindsight I think you know his decision
a while back to talk openly about
Anthony Davis and the idea that he would
love to play with them I understand
giving respect to your peers but it you
know unfortunately you know what comes
with that is the danger of disrespect to
your teammates and now it's playing out
in a really real time kind of way all
these guys in that Lakers locker room
have seen they're all in social media I
mean I've been in Lakers locker room
plenty this year and I'm not kidding it
may be more than any locker room in the
entire league you walk in there postgame
and every single guys on his phone in
fact I talked to Brandon Ingram about
that once like everybody's looking at
their social media they see their names
out there in the public realm and then
they look up I'm sitting there saying
hey guys let's think about you know we
over me and the team first right it's
like you got a bunch of guys on expiring
contracts or young players who know that
they might get shipped it's just a bad
bad situation and you know I think again
with LeBron you know maybe if you would
have just let everything unfold behind
the scenes and and kind of try to
navigate this thing that way maybe
they'd still be in a better place I know
it's it's quote-unquote just one game
but it was awful and the stakes are
really high because if they don't get
the AV thing done now all of a sudden
you got bad morale and you're two and a
half games behind the Clippers for that
age spot at the moment Clippers are
gonna fall out the team's like the kings
want to get in the play Pierce you know
there's other teams that might playoffs
which would certainly not be no do we
drop Sam okay we got to get Sam back
because you stole my thunder
no no you good because you stole my
thunder there because here we are
talking about all of these trades and
how teams can bolster themselves and
Anthony Davis and this and that but yet
no one's talking and I look and I get it
but you've been around that team for
about ten plus years when you were
working as a beat writer for the
Sacramento Kings but what a job that
they've done I know it's not you know
national
News but what they've done especially
winning 28 games in the West
Mike this is what some of they've teamed
at the bottom should be looking at when
people laughed at Vlade Divac cadet
organization they've won 28 games right
now and it kid like you mentioned could
be possibly making a tray to get into
the playoffs if they get to the playoffs
the Sacramento Kings what does that say
about the organization they'd be in a
great place it'd be one of the more
memorable you know in terms of the
timeline and the speed of a turnaround
it would be one of the more memorable
ones we've seen lately I mean if you hit
the rewind button and card you know you
go back to that night New Orleans
all-star weekend a couple years ago when
DeMarcus Cousins is getting traded yeah
you know the kings of Lodi are just
getting roundly ridiculed for that deal
and then you had a little bit of salt in
that wound because you know and I've
always not been comfortable with this I
felt like Lodi has done plenty of things
to deserve some criticism 100% what else
it was happened is there's there's this
kind of cultural thing where you know
because he done English as his second
language you know when he traded to
Marcus he came out and he he kind of
told the press that hey I had a better
trainer on the table and then I ended up
taking this one and that always got lost
in translation because what it actually
happened was the Marcus's people scared
the pelicans so much about the Marcus
potentially resigning that they took a
first rounder off the table so the Kings
couldn't control that part you know so
yes at one point in time there was
something better there but still this
pack is that everybody thought was an
absolute joke has been the catalyst for
their turnaround and it has led to you
know the losing that season led to them
getting Darren Fox but he Hill turned
into a much better player and a lot of
people thought he was going to be Justin
Jackson's come around a little bit
lately and they're on their way and now
with Harry Giles and Marvin Bagley and
you know in this young core they're
exciting and it's weird for me because
I'm still based near Sacramento and it's
been so long since I like I'm going to
the Kings Rockets game tonight and it's
been so long since it was February and
you're going to the arena actually
planning on watching a relevant
basketball game as opposed to you know
just another team that's going to roll
through town and win by 20 or just going
for the halftime show right the the
halftime act
but hey last question before I let you
me it like I go to interview I go to
connect with coaches players all those
things that averages I would sit there
and wish the game would just end quicker
because the game was inconsequential for
my purposes now admittedly it's
entertaining man they're a fun team they
play up-tempo and and they're given is
they just be freely at home you know and
then have some big time wins it's been a
fun yeah last question before I let you
go Sam because the one thing is that the
trade deadline like I mentioned will be
tomorrow through 12 SR 3 p.m. Eastern
time but in 30 seconds how much do the
agents of these players like you just
mentioned to mention with DeMarcus
Cousins last year how much do the agents
have to do with possibly what's going to
happen over the next 24 hours I think
there's a correlation between how much
the team's let them impact negotiations
and then then taking that power when
it's available we're seeing it with the
Lakers and pelicans right now it's
sloppy it's messy everybody's name is
out there everybody's pulling power
plays so it does definitely happen but
then you see the opposite when a team
like the Clippers does this deal with
Philly kind of in the dark at night the
next did the same thing with porzingis
that happens very quickly so you know as
much as I love reporting on the drama
and the names and the details it's not
good for business when it comes to the
teams hey Sam I appreciate the time has
always been and have fun tonight see if
James Harden can extend his streak
tonight Thank You Kirk good I appreciate
I will say I'm aiming to see your NBA
Ryder from the athletic the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience